president biden is still locked in final
negotiations on his agenda to strengthen
america's safety net he promoted the
plan yesterday where in new jersey the
state's democratic governor is running
for a second term tonight he turns his
attention to the virginia governor's
race where democrat terry mcauliffe is
in danger of losing to republican glenn
yonkin ed o'keefe is at the white house
ed good morning hey nate good morning to
you with democrats still struggling to
come up with the details of the
president's social spending plan and
even as he prepares for big global
meetings in europe later this week the
president tonight has to attend to party
politics because his party is locked in
two competitive governors races and
usually reliably blue states
let's give president joe biden a brick
jersey welcome
in this year's two governors races in
new jersey and virginia republicans are
hoping for upsets so the president's
headed to virginia tonight to campaign
for democrat terry mcauliffe it's an
appearance that comes amid record low
public support for the president
especially among independent voters
which could signal bigger trouble for
democrats ahead of next year's midterm
elections hey guys that's why the
president stopped by a new jersey
classroom monday to highlight his
party's plans for early childhood
education democrats are preparing to
enact about 450 billion dollars in
funding for universal pre-k and child
care stipends we'll make two years of
high quality preschool available to
every child in america but almost every
other part of the biden plan is still up
for debate in order to keep moderates
like west virginia joe manchin on board
democrats are scaling back and i think
that
we've got a good understanding of each
other now better than we've ever had
instead of 12 weeks of paid family leave
it may be whittled down to four
instead of medicare paying for all
dental work new 800 vouchers could be
offered and instead of raising income
tax rates a tax on billionaires could
pay for some of those new programs
meanwhile activists continue to chase
after another moderate democrat arizona
senator kirsten cinema as they try to
figure out if she's on board what are
you going to do about climate change
next week in glasgow could be the last
chance
please answer me senator my family my
house
from tucson were constituents
the clock is also ticking on the
president's popular bipartisan
infrastructure bill remember that well
federal highway funding is set to expire
in five days and it could lapse because
house progressives say they won't vote
on that infrastructure bill and send it
to the president's desk until there's a
deal signed or sealed with those two
moderate senators joe manchin and
kirsten cinema on the president's
broader social spending plan tarika
the staring contest continues here in
washington exactly i was
i was just saying that ed thank you so
much